hey this is presh talwalkar
can you solve this problem from a
national exam in malaysia
a cylindrical container with length 20
centimeters is placed on the floor
against the wall as shown in the diagram
point q is on the edge of the base
and q is two centimeters from the wall
and one centimeter from the floor
can the cylindrical container fit inside
a box whose dimensions are 21
centimeters by seven centimeters by
seven centimeters
why or why not
now there's an unstated assumption that
the wall is perpendicular to the floor
this is something most of us would
assume but it's not necessarily true
there are walls and floors that are
not perpendicular
but go ahead and assume the wall is
perpendicular and that this is a perfect
right cylinder
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so how can we figure out if the
cylindrical container can fit inside a
box with these dimensions
we need to check if the cylinders
dimensions are smaller than the box's
dimensions
we know one dimension of the cylinder is
20 centimeters
and that is smaller than the box's
dimension of 21 centimeters
so that dimension will fit inside the
box
the other dimensions of the cylinder are
equal to the diameter of the circle
this will be the width and the height
which will be equal to the circle's
diameter
the question is
is the circle's diameter smaller than
seven centimeters or larger than seven
centimeters
how can we figure it out
the only piece of information we're
given
is that q
is two centimeters from the wall and one
centimeter from the floor
so we can try and numerically estimate
what the circle's dimensions need to be
we'll plot out the floor on the x-axis
and the wall on the y-axis
we'll use a little bit of graph paper
and we'll draw a diagram that's two
scale so that we can make a numerical
estimate
point q is two units from the wall and
one unit from the floor
so we'll mark this point as a negative
two one because it's two units left of
the wall and one unit above the floor
so what kind of circle would touch both
the floor and the wall and pass through
point q
well let's try and numerically estimate
this
here's a circle that contains q it
touches the wall on the floor but it's
not exactly passing through a queue and
here's a circle that's touching the wall
on the floor that's too big
so let's use a computer simulation to
imagine growing the blue circle and
shrinking the green circle
to get exactly what kind of circle we
would need that passes through queue and
touches both the floor and the wall
it turns out there is a unique circle
with this property
we can now measure the circle's
dimensions by counting the units on this
plot
the width will be equal to 10 units or
10 centimeters and the height will be
also 10 centimeters
so if all we cared about was solving
this problem numerically we've figured
it out
the circle is not smaller
than 7 centimeters in its diameter the
circle is 10 centimeters by 10
centimeters
so the circle's width and height are too
large for the box that has dimensions of
seven centimeters by seven centimeters
so in one way we found the answer
before mathematician this may be
unsatisfying
while we have found a method to
numerically estimate the diameter how
can we solve for the exact value
furthermore we solve for a specific
value of q but what if q was a different
value
by what method could we solve the
problem quickly for other values of q
it wouldn't be cumbersome to keep on
trying to do the simulation for every
single value of q
but we might be able to come up with a
formula so that we can instantly figure
out what the dimensions of the circle
would be for any value of q
so how can we approach the problem and
solve this more generally
we'll use the same approach
we'll have the floor on the x-axis and
the wall on the y-axis
we have a circle that's passing through
point q
which will be negative two one
there's one more thing we know about the
circle
it's tangent to the floor and the wall
so we can draw a square
as such
and each of these dimensions will be one
radius of the circle
so one radius left of the wall will be
negative r
and one radius above the floor will be
positive r
this will be the circle's center at
negative r comma r
we want to find a circle centered at the
point negative r comma r that passes
through the point q which equals
negative 2 1.
a circle that is centered at negative r
and has a radius of r
has the equation the quantity x plus r
squared plus the quantity y minus r
squared equals r squared
we want this circle to pass through the
point q which equals negative 2 1.
so we'll substitute the value x equals
negative 2 and y equals one into the
above equation
this gives the quadratic equation the
quantity negative two plus r squared
plus the quantity one minus r squared
equals r squared
we now have an equation in a single
variable r
we can expand out each of these
binomials and then collect like terms to
one side to get the following quadratic
equation
r squared minus six r plus five equals
zero
this can be factored into the quantity r
minus five and the quantity r minus one
we have two solutions
r equals five or r equals one
let's check the solution r equals one
in that case the point q
would not be in the corner between the
wall and the floor it would actually be
on the other side of the circle
so this does not correspond to our
original diagram and the problem that
we're trying to solve so we reject the
solution r equals one
this means r is equal to five and the
diameter of the circle is two times r
which equals ten centimeters just as
before
so once again we figured out the
circle's diameter is larger than seven
centimeters but we figured out an exact
value
and we can take this method and
generalize it to solve for any value of
q
where q is equal to negative a b
we use the same general equation for a
circle that's centered at negative r r
and has a radius of r
we then need this circle to pass through
the point q equals negative a b
so we substitute x equals negative a and
y equals b
and we end up with the following
equation
once again we can expand each term and
then collect like terms
we end up with the following quadratic
equation and we can then use the
quadratic formula to get that the
answers would be r is equal to a plus b
plus or minus the square root of 2 a b
we would then check if either solution
satisfies the original constraints of
the problem and that would give us the
value for r
did you figure out this problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description
you can also support me on patreon
you can also catch me on social media
either at mindyourdecisions or at
preshtalwalkar depending on the site